hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
welcome to the ultimate max studio
comparison and when i say ultimate i
mean it because for the past week we've
been putting all three of these max
studio models to the test and we found
some groundbreaking bombshell
information in terms of diminishing
returns and which one of these you
should be buying so without further ado
i want to mention which specs each one
of these has in terms of the specs the
base model has the m1 max with the bend
24 core gpu and 32 gigabytes of unified
memory then the middle model has the m1
ultra with the bend 48 core gpu with 64
gigs of unified memory so double the
memory and then the final model has
double the memory again
128 gigs with the full unlocked 64 core
gpu and by the end of this ultimate
comparison you are going to know exactly
which one of these models you should be
buying based on your specific use case
so before we actually get into the
benchmarks i want to talk about a couple
of the differences first of all both of
the m1 ultra models have two thunderbolt
ports in the front compared to just usb
type c on the base m1 max model and the
other difference is that the m1 ultras
actually have a really beefy
fully copper double-sided cooling system
as we showed you guys in our full
teardown video compared to the m1 max
that has a much more traditional cooling
system no longer double-sided but it is
still pretty impressive but other than
that they're basically all identical
with no other design or spec or poor
differences and with that said let's
jump right into performance starting off
with geekbench 5's single core test
where they're all performing basically
the same and the reason for that is
because they all have the same cores the
m1 ultra just doubles the amount of cpu
cores but they're still the same core so
that's why there's no difference in
single core performance and that
actually translates to basically the
same performance in terms of web
browsing with the speedometer 2.0 test
so in terms of snappiness for common
tasks like web browsing or opening apps
other stuff like that they should all be
the same so no difference going from the
2k up to the crazy fully loaded 8k model
but now let's move over to the
multi-core test and of course since the
m1 ultras have basically double the
cores they're getting almost perfect
scaling for double the multi-core
performance it's just lacking by a
little bit but it's still a very
impressive score and then when we move
over to a more realistic benchmark that
puts in 100 cpu workload like cinebench
r23 we actually see almost the same
results almost two times perfect scaling
which is actually very impressive but we
dug deep into acid top and the actual
watts that are used between the m1 max
and the m1 ultras and we noticed that
apple is allowing the m1 ultras to push
more wattage towards the m1 ultra chips
in order to maintain that almost two
times perfect scaling because the peak
wattage we saw in cinebench with the m1
max was actually 27.66
watts but going over to the m1 ultra it
was actually over double the wattage up
to 58 watts so apple is actually giving
more power to the ultras to try to
maintain that scaling but the very
interesting thing is that cinebench is
actually not utilizing these chips very
well because i tested the peak wattage
in a different app and it was actually
quite a bit higher for example i ran a
lightroom photo export and i was able to
get these edwin ultra chips to go up to
68 watts of peak usage yes 68 and i got
the m1 max in the base model up to 32
watts of power usage so once again this
proves that apple is willing to pump
extra wattage into the m1 ultra chips to
maintain the scaling which is a very
very good sign and in terms of the
performance in that lightroom photo
export both of the m1 ultras finished in
45 seconds compared to a minute and 22
seconds for the m1 max model and that is
actually 82
faster so these m1 ultras 82 faster than
the base m1 max which is not perfect
scaling because there are a lot of other
factors included in that test but it's
still very impressive and it's an
extremely fast score compared to older
computers but with that said for this
ultimate comparison we wanted to add in
a couple more photo editing tests so we
did an absolutely insane panorama where
we took 16 50 megapixel photos and then
had lightroom classic create a panorama
and interestingly in here the m1 ultra
models were only 48
faster so you're really getting some
diminishing returns once it's processing
the panoramas which is very interesting
so we decided to also test photoshop and
basically do the same auto merge
panorama and i think photoshop actually
does a better job at combining it and
getting rid of distortion
however the m1 ultra models this time
around were only 20
faster so i don't know if there's some
weird optimization issues but like if
you're looking at that test the m1 max
is doing a killer job considering the
price and now with photo editing out of
the way let's move over to programming
within xcode and of course we are using
our xcode benchmark that maxim eramanco
made for us and in this test we got some
very interesting results first of all
going from the base machine to the best
m1 ultra with 128 gigs of unified memory
only gave us a boost of 35
so 35 faster for this machine which
honestly isn't that impressive and it
was only three seconds faster than the
mid-range machine that has 64 gigs of
unified memory so literally having
double the memory saved us three seconds
on that xcode benchmark so it kind of
looks like the memory is not really
being used that well at least for this
xcode benchmark so it looks like apple
silicon is doing a great job but only 35
from here to here however moving on to
music production using logic pro we
actually saw some really good scaling
the m1 max model was able to handle 173
tracks before the cpu overloaded but
then going over to the best of the best
and when ultra with 128 gigs it handled
341 tracks which is absolutely insane
that's 97
more tracks than the m1 max and
interestingly this is actually the test
where we saw a difference with the
unified memory because the 128 gig model
was able to handle 26 extra tracks
solely because of the doubling and
unified memory but to be completely
honest over 300 tracks is overkill for
basically almost anybody and even 173 on
the m1 max is probably good enough for
most people in logic so these are all
very impressive and now with some of the
cpu based stuff out of the way let's
pivot over to the graphics starting with
geekbench 5's metal test and here you
can see some significant diminishing
returns going from the m1 max of the m1
ultra with the 48 core and then the 64
core and i do want to explain the
underwhelming results that's because
geekbench has really fast short burst
kind of things that it does so it never
ramps up the gpu wattage high enough so
it's not really reliable so we're gonna
switch over to gfx bench benchmark with
the 1440p aztec ruins off-screen test
and this is where things get very
disappointing because going from the 24
core bend m1 max to the 48 core bend m1
ultra so that's double the gpu cores
we're only getting 72 percent higher
performance and then going up to the 64
core it's even worse only 17
faster now that is extremely
disappointing because this model
just for unlocking the 64 core gpu it
costs a thousand dollars that's before
changing the unified memory or the
storage or anything literally a thousand
dollars to go from 48 to 64 and we're
getting 17
higher performance which is just so
disappointing so with that said we
decided to test 3dmark's wildlife
extreme benchmark which we think is more
optimized and we basically saw the same
disappointing results going from the 24
core m1 max to the 64 core m1 ultra was
only 2.24
times faster which is definitely
disappointing so what we decided to do
was break it down in terms of score per
gpu core and here you can see that the
highest end m1 ultra is really
underwhelming and it's just not being
utilized that well at all with the best
bang for the buck actually going to the
24 core edwin max so we started to
search for an answer to why this is
happening why we are getting such bad
diminishing returns and we actually
found it by measuring the peak wattage
with all three of these different
machines during wildlife extreme
unlimited the 24 core m1 max hit 34.98
watts peak while the 48 core doubled and
when ultra hit
68.26 so that's almost double the amount
of power however going up to the 64 core
we only saw 86.14
watts which seems extremely low because
apple showed off over 100 watts of power
usage going to the gpu but that is not
what we're seeing here at all only 86.
so going even further we decided to
break down how much watts each chip is
giving each gpu so essentially the
wattage per gpu core and as you can see
as you go higher in terms of the amount
of cores they're giving it less watts
per core so this is actually a major
contrast to the cpu because apple was
pumping in extra watts into the cpus to
try to get double the scaling but with
the gpus they're actually doing the
opposite the more gpu cores you have
they're reducing the total wattage which
is very disappointing so that makes me
wonder what if there's some sort of
power limit or flaw on the gpu side
while not on the cpu side and i'm gonna
answer that in just a couple of minutes
but before i get into that crazy video
editing torture test that we ran to
prove it i want to give a shout out to
our new premium m1 ultra design hoodie
yes this thing looks really good it's
ultra soft ultra premium and it shows
off the m1 ultra chip it's our own
custom design so if you want to show
your support for all this crazy work
that we've been doing and testing please
use a promo code m1 ultra for 20 off on
all of our merch that you can find in
our merch shelf below now before i get
into blender 3d video rendering i do
want to get into the affinity photo
benchmark and here this is actually very
interesting because we got almost
perfect 99
scaling in terms of the cpu benchmark
performance going from the m1 max to
both of the ultra so that's a very good
sign but once again looking at the gpu
scaling it is absolutely horrible going
from the 24 core m1 max the 48 core m1
ultra we only got 56 percent better
performance which sucks because it
should be double if it was properly
scaled and this is affinity photo which
is actually very well optimized with
metal but going from 48 cores to 64
we literally only got 6 percent better
performance which is just so odd and
just so disappointing and unfortunately
these results also transferred over into
blender 3d rendering we tested the party
tug example project render and here the
64 core was only 13 faster than the 48
core once again crazy diminishing
returns but thankfully comparing the 24
core m1 max to the 48 core m1 ultra it
was actually 91 faster which is by far
the best scaling we've seen so it must
be something in terms of the unified
memory with the 64 gigs of ram that is
really helping out the gpu rendering
compared to the m1 max that's limited to
32 gigs so with that said we also ran
the classroom gpu render with the cycles
engine but here it was no longer 91 it
was actually 70 faster going from the m1
max to the m1 ultra with 48 cores but
unfortunately it was even worse for the
64 core only 11
faster compared to the 48 course so even
worse diminishing returns right there
and then as for the last test and
blender i actually decided to run
classroom but with the cpu instead of
the gpu just to test out the scaling for
cpu rendering and here it was actually
pretty impressive going from the 10 core
m1 max to the 20 core m1 ultra we got 95
faster performance so almost two time
scaling which is really nice but the
interesting part with this test is that
this model with the extra ram 128 gigs
compared to 64 was even faster yes this
m1 ultra was 18 faster and the only
difference was the unified memory the
doubling in the ram so i guess blender
is really able to use the ram and it
does speed up performance so that's nice
but you got to think is the extra
thousand dollars worth the 18 well if
you have very large projects then maybe
it is but you make that decision for
yourself and now finally let's get into
video editing where we found some
bombshell differences in terms of the
diminishing returns between these three
but before i begin i do want to mention
that max is going to be doing a
dedicated video editing video testing
multiple apps final cut davinci resolve
premiere pro comparing the differences
between all of these getting into export
times into playback and timeline
performance all that stuff so if you're
interested definitely click subscribe so
you do not miss out on that but for this
video i'm gonna keep it to the things
that you really need to know about and
the first test that we ran is our basic
general five minute 4k
8.264 export and yes that is graded with
two luts and film grain applied this is
basically the most common kodak that a
lot of people are using in fact we are
still using it to shoot and export and
edit ourselves and here you'll be
surprised to hear that they all scored
exactly the same time a minute and 52
seconds
and i think the reason for it is because
final cut has not been upgraded or
updated yet
even though these mac studios came out
we're still on the old version and apple
has not given us a new one so literally
no difference and that basically means
that the doubled media engines or the
doubled encoders and decoders are not
being utilized at all which is extremely
disappointing right now and just to make
sure that's the case we actually did the
same export within davinci resolve and
here we actually got faster performance
compared to final cut we finished in
around a minute and 40 seconds once
again across all three of this machines
so davinci resolve is also not updated
yet to support the doubled media engines
but the big point that i do want to
mention is that during these exports we
measured the gpu usage to see how much
of an overhead you have just in case you
want to throw on a ton of extra graphics
lens flares whatever else and
surprisingly the m1 max was only using
53
of the gpu so you still have a bunch of
gpu overhead even with the 24 core gpu
and going to the craziest 64 core it was
only using 35 and i'd actually expect a
bigger difference but it's using 35
compared to 53 so basically there's
really no point
right now at least to go for the ultras
if you're just doing basic h.264 exports
and now over the last couple of years we
actually got a new standard that was
introduced and that's hevc or h.265
and that is actually more efficient
because you get a much smaller file size
you get better quality as well and as
you'll see right now you actually get
faster export speeds so we tested it in
final cut and that time came down to a
minute and 17 seconds for both m1 ultras
and actually a minute 23 for the m1 max
so for some reason it's a little bit
slower and the reason for that is
because the 24 core is just ever so
slightly bottlenecking it so it's five
seconds slower because it doesn't have
enough gpu power due to only having the
24 cores compared to the 48 and 64. but
with that said we actually threw the
same export test into davinci resolve
and our times came down to around 49
seconds each yes only 49 seconds for
this five minute export keep in mind
it's graded with two luts and film grain
that is very impressive so davinci
resolve is currently being better than
final cut and we actually ended up
looking at the gpu usage and even the m1
max was using 79 of the gpu so it's
almost perfectly balanced it still has a
little bit of wiggle room 21
of gpu overhead if you want to add a
little bit more but if you add a lot
more you are going to be throttled
compared to these other machines where
the mid machine was at 65 gpu usage and
52 gpu usage on the 64 course so there
are some diminishing returns there and
you have a lot of extra headroom if you
want to throw in a lot of extra graphics
and things like that but once again i do
want to mention that due to those
results around 49 seconds each these m1
ultras are definitely being throttled by
the encoders so they're just hitting the
limit and the extra encoders are not
being used at all so let's pivot over to
something that is purely gpu based yes
this is 8k redraw so it cannot take
advantage of any encoders any decoders
it's purely based on the gpu and here we
actually saw a similar story in terms of
diminishing returns going from the 24
core m1 max to the 48 core m1 ultra only
37.5
faster so doubling the gpu cores only
37.5 percent so
very diminishing returns there but then
going from the 48 core to the 64 we
actually got 23 faster so only five
minutes and 25 compared to six minutes
and 40 and that right there could
actually be a big deal for you guys
doing 8k redraw or whatever else redraw
you're doing 23 faster for a thousand
dollars that could actually be
worth it for a lot of people especially
since this is actually only a five
minute redraw export imagine if you have
an hour long project like you're gonna
save a lot of time going from the 48 to
the 64. so this could actually be worth
it but then that wasn't enough for us we
wanted to do something crazy so we did a
torture test yes we exported canon raw
that's 8k raw to 4k hevc that is our
torture test because it basically maxes
out the cpu and the gpu at the same time
and here is where we saw by far the most
disappointing results out of this entire
video going from the 2 000 base model to
the 4 000 bend 48 core gpu only gave us
25
faster export times so that's extreme
diminishing returns right there but
making things even worse going from this
mid machine to the 64 core with
literally double the unified memory
only four percent faster that is
absolutely terrible maxing out both the
cpu and the gpu and to us this made
absolutely zero sense until we dug into
the peak wattage and the gpu frequencies
where it just got so disappointing
apparently in this test
all three of the gpus were throttled yes
the peak should be 1300 megahertz but
the m1 max clocked down to
1255 megahertz but the mid-range m1
ultra clocked down to 912 megahertz yes
it is throttling it for some reason and
the 64 core gpu model clocked down to
752
megahertz it is getting extremely slowed
down into our surprise we looked at the
wattage that was being used for the gpu
and the m1 max with 24 cores for the gpu
was actually using more wattage
than the fully loaded 64 core gpu 25.1
compared to 22.5
with the mid-range using the most
wattage towards the gpu which is
absolutely mind-blowing and it just
makes no sense at all so with that said
i've gotta answer the question of why
the m1 ultras are getting down clocked
severely and why the wattage is getting
down clocked so badly and in my opinion
i think there's some sort of power limit
or m1 max die design flaw that is not
allowing apple to push both the cpu and
the gpu to the max so they're basically
prioritizing the cpu but they're cutting
back on the gpu in terms of the wattage
and the frequencies
and you might be thinking well maybe
it's thermal throttling maybe they're
overheating well it's not it's
absolutely not at all we measured the
cpu and gpu temperatures at the end of
this crazy canon export and the 64 core
gpu
in the m1 ultra was only 57 degrees
celsius and the cpu was only 68 degrees
celsius with the other two being around
the same that is extremely cool because
apple used to be able to go up to 100
degrees celsius on both the cpu gpu
no problem that's usually their limit
but here you can see that there's a
massive amount of thermal headroom so it
is not thermal throttling at all it is
something different and i think for some
reason they just can't supply enough
power into both the cpu and the gpu at
the same time so they gotta down clock
the gpu and let me remind you guys that
this is literally the craziest torture
test possible because it's set to max
out both the cpu and gpu at the same
time but because of this weird internal
die power limit it just drops it down
and it's not able to supply all the
power and it's not able to fire up all
the gpu cores at maximum performance and
this is really unfortunate because apple
threw in this crazy copper heatsink with
the double-sided cooling and it is just
not able to ever
utilize it and actually make use of that
cooler and the craziest thing is that
when we initially tore down these models
and we compared the m1 max heatsink to
the crazy copper double-sided heatsink
on the m1 ultra we thought that these
machines would be running cooler they
would be able to supply more power
they'd be able to run quieter with the
fan speeds but no absolutely not the m1
max model only ran slightly hotter so
literally these crazy cooling systems
are not being used it's almost like
apple had this huge disconnect between
their design team their cooling team and
their actual chip team where the chip
team was saying like hey we need double
of everything for the m1 max it's got to
supply and cool down this crazy amount
of power so they went all out they've
got the copper they got this thick heat
sink with the crazy fans but there was a
disconnect because
for some reason they cannot supply the
full amount of power to those gpu cores
so there is severe diminishing returns
when both the cpu and gpu are used at
the same time and you're probably
thinking well maybe there's a fan noise
difference maybe these ones are able to
run more silently well no because
throughout all this testing every single
test we ran i never heard the fans go
above idle literally your ac noise or
whatever ambient noise overpowers the
idle fans you can't even hear them no
matter what test we ran completely
silent across all three of these
machines and that's even when we ran
cinebench and wildlife extreme at the
same time and that's even when i did my
ultimate gaming test i literally
couldn't hear the fans and the chips
were cool the entire time so these
cooling systems are completely overkill
so hopefully it's meant to be future
proofed for the m2 ultra in the future
so it can supply more power maybe if
apple fixes that weird design flaw
within the max dies and they could
actually supply the actual amount of
power that we need but for now like they
could have made these mac studios a lot
smaller and it would be just fine but
they just went all out but anyway with
all that said let me get into my final
conclusions if you just need common web
browsing and common app performance like
that the m1 max based model for two
grand is obviously the best choice and
it actually has by far the best bang for
the buck seeing as we're getting so much
diminishing returns with these m1 ultra
machines now if you mainly just care
about cpu performance maybe for photo
editing lightroom classic exporting
affinity photo or 3d rendering using the
cpu i'd say that going up to the m1
ultra is actually worth it because
you're getting a lot of extra
performance for the extra cash but i'd
say the 128 gig model i don't think i
would recommend that to anybody because
you're really getting diminishing
returns in terms of that ram at least
for cpu performance benchmarks and tests
so with that said most people just need
to stick to 64 gigs of unified memory do
not get the 128 so for cp performance
yes the m1 ultra is worth it but now
let's get into the gpu if you're doing
blender 3d rendering with the gpu i'd
say that going for the m1 ultra with 48
cores is definitely worth it but paying
a thousand dollars for 11 or 13
faster performance for the 64 core i
don't think that's worth it at all for
blender because you're just paying so
much money for such a small improvement
in blender and then finally getting into
video editing this is by far not worth
it at all it's just extreme diminishing
returns it's not really able to take
advantage of the 64 core gpu so video
editors out there you should probably
stick to the 48 core only 64 gigs of
unified memory do not get 128 now the
only test out of all those video editing
tests where i think it might be worth
going for the crazy 64 core is of course
the 8k red where we got 23 faster
performance and once again you've got to
spend a thousand dollars to get 23
faster in 8k red so that's your choice
on whether you think it's worth it or
not but to be completely honest if
you're a video editor and you care about
bank for the buck this thing right here
for two grand is by far the best deal
because right now the m1 ultras are not
utilizing the extra media engines at all
whatsoever and you're not even getting
that good of performance improvements
paying double the money so for video
editors this thing's actually killer and
i definitely recommend this as the best
bang for the buck option but if you want
to spend more money to squeeze out a
little bit more performance especially
if final cut gets updated to support the
media engines then i'd say just stick to
the four grand model here just do not
get the 64 core i honestly don't think
anybody should be going for the 64 core
or the 128 gigs of unified memory unless
you know you want to squeeze out just
the tiniest bit of performance and
you're willing to spend the extra cash
and with that said that was a lot of
stuff that we tested so hopefully you
enjoy the video and if you appreciate
all the work we did please subscribe for
more videos like this one because we
have some more content coming up
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]